good morning heck it's tuesday so for
the last i don't know like 21 weeks or
so i've been thinking a lot about the
lyric
all that glitters is gold which appears
in the 1971 classic led
zeppelin song stairway to heaven and
then reappears many years later
in all star by smash mouth it's a
strange lyric because it's manifestly
untrue like much that glitters is not
gold including
glitter and that observation goes back a
long way like in merchant of venice
immediately after shakespeare writes all
that glisters is not gold
he adds often you have heard that told
like it was a cliche back then
two centuries earlier chaucer wrote it
not all gold that glareth and aesop made
a similar observation
2600 years ago all that glitters is not
gold is a reminder that we can't always
trust our senses that superficial truth
is often deeply misleading and that what
seems at a distance to be wonderful or
precious
often turns out not to be to cite one
example from my own life when i was
younger i thought that being famous was
like the most glitteringly magnificent
thing that could happen to a person
but then i got to see it up close and
realized that it was a little more
complicated
but what's up with the notion that all
that glitters is gold well i suppose i
should stop here and acknowledge that
i'm
not an expert at analyzing song lyrics
you know what there are some people who
can tell you that such and such song by
the mountain goats is about a maoist
rebellion in the 1970s or whatever
i never think that way i always think
that every song by the mountain goats is
about
me and how i feel listening to the song
and what it makes me think about in my
own life
so i'm not an expert song analyst also i
don't think that poems or songs or
whatever exist
primarily as riddles to be solved i
think artix is primarily not to be
figured out but to be
lived with and around and also other
prepositions
but right the lyrics to that led
zeppelin song begin there's a lady who's
sure all that glitters is gold and she's
buying
a stairway to heaven so this is
presented as a presumably naive belief
that all that glitters is gold and if
you just collect enough of this
glittering gold you can
buy a stairway to heaven but 28 years
later when smash mouth repurposes the
lyric now it seems like it's just about
the life of a rock star you get the show
on you get paid
all that glitters is gold now this gets
a little more interesting and
complicated if you consider that the
original lyric that followed all that
glitters is gold
was wave bye-bye to your soul like yeah
you're going to get rich and it's going
to feel like everything that glitters is
gold but you are going to lose your soul
in the process just like the led
zeppelin character can't buy
their way into heaven the smash mouth
character can't rock star their way into
heaven which is maybe or maybe not what
smash mouth had in mind when they wrote
the lyric but and this may surprise you
i don't really care about smash mouth or
what they had in mind
what is important to me is what all that
glitters is gold
makes me feel when i hear people sing it
there are moments in human life that
feel
genuinely magical when you find yourself
on some adventure or when you're having
an amazing conversation with people you
really love or when you're sitting
backstage watching your brother play
music to a crowd that's singing along
your moments will be different but i
think we all have them these little
moments where we feel
infinite to borrow a word from stephen
chbosky and for me anyway in those
moments it's almost like you can feel a
memory being presently
formed and it really does feel like all
that glitters
is gold and what i love most about music
in the end is the way the songs i love
even the stupid songs i love
contain both the warmth of past memory
and the warmth of
future hope hank i'll see you on friday
oh one last thing this video contains a
clue
and the clue leads in a roundabout way
to a secret live stream you can learn
more about the clue and find people to
help solve it with you
in the comments below there was also a
clue last week and in the coming weeks
there will
often but not always be clues i think
that's all i have to say on the matter